among the many shocking developments and
Avengers endgame Thor's transformation
from buff god of thunder to the press
dad bard has to rank near the top of the
list and while there's a lot to love
about this narrative twist it's far from
perfect here are the three best and the
worst things about Vic Thor heroes
always have their low points but Thor's
is pretty darn low he spends the bulk of
infinity war off on his own side quests
in the hopes of coming back with a
weapon that could ultimately turn the
tide and it almost does too when we get
to endgame though
Thor isn't just distracted by his own
motivations and plans he's completely
lost his way throughout much of endgame
bro Thor as Marvel officially labels him
in a blu-ray featurettes continually
makes poor decisions and prioritizes its
own needs over everyone else's this is
immediately made clear when rocky and
professor Hulk arrive in new Asgard to
find out the king is hiding away playing
video games and only interacts with his
people in order to restock on beer and
what about when he time travels to
Asgard with rocky in order to extract
the ether from his old flame Jane Foster
he crumbles in fear as soon as the
rubber hits the road leading Rockets
tough-guy pep talk to help him turn a
corner which even then doesn't work by
the time Avengers and Thor the dark
world rolled around the 1 dimensional
aspect of Thor's character as a
muscle-bound hero was getting old fast
the early mana stations of the son of
Odin were powerful and all but there
just wasn't much substance there that is
until director Taika Waititi arrived on
the scene thor ragnarok reinvigorated
the thor franchise with a humongous
energy that thrilled audiences across
the board the three call strips down
Thor story - its emotionally raw
underpinnings and provides the perfect
springboard to carry the character
through his vengeful mission and
Avengers infinity war in dens game the
bro Thor narrative twists a story even
further dragging the Asgardian to all
new lows before ultimately bringing him
some long-awaited emotional resolution
the developments in Thor story from
Ragnarok through endgame it didn't seem
possible in the early days of the second
phase of the MCU and the entire affair
stands at the testament to the inherent
potential of the character possesses for
all of his heroics and character
development over the years
Thor really is still a gruff warrior at
his core that's why he went off in
search of a bigger badder weapon when
Thanos arrived on the scene if he could
outgun his opponents he knew he could
win by sheer brute force but while his
strong handed approach to life has been
instrumental a multiple
earth and universe saving occasions as
one moment an endgame that exposes how
nasty Thor's belligerents competitive
attitude can get when he's off duty when
rocket and Hulk arrive at force hurts
the trio of heroes catch up on the past
five years and discuss future plans
while Korg plays fortnight off to the
side at one point Korg inform saw that
news master 69 is giving him a hard time
again at which point the god of thunder
crabs his friends headset and delivers a
thundering string of threats including
literally flying to the person's house
and tearing off his arms the little
spurt of cyberbullying exposes the fact
that while Thor's brazen approach to
life may work out well in the hero
departments when it comes to the regular
everyday stuff he sometimes ends up
looking like a bully Thor is an alien he
can fly around the universe using the
Bifrost the guy survived floating
through space until the guardians of the
galaxy picked him up in infinity war and
yet over the years he's become one of
the most oddly relatable characters in
the MCU in spite of the rather
exaggerated nature of everything he does
the truth is Thoris had some very human
struggles over the years a fact that is
on full display during endgame it
suffered heartbreak and emotional trauma
more than once leading up to the film
but as it ends gain that we come face to
face with the Thor that is truly
relatable as he grapples with his
emotions struggles through depression
and faces the consequences for his
actions it becomes easier than ever to
connect with the god on entirely new
levels on a more practical note his
hefty appearance also creates new
frontiers thoughts Bart opens up a whole
new world for cosplayers to connect with
their favorite Avenger without feeling
inadequate in the process while the son
of Odin is a heavy hitter whether he's
sporting a beer gut or nut when you
break it down or the extra weight in
years of an activity in endgame do seem
to take their toll on the Asgardians
ability to keep up or is he asleep Thor
is definitely slower this time around
in fact Hemsworth film seems of waits on
his hands and ankles to change the
appearance of his walk he also doesn't
make quite as big of a splash in the
final battle as he did say when he
arrived in Wakanda in infinity war in
fact this time around he finds himself
somehow matched by Thanos and he
ultimately needs to be bailed out by the
Mjolnir wielding Steve Rogers through
that
of course it's natural that he'd be a
bit rusty after taking five years off
and packing on so many pounds there's no
question that the effects of his new
lifestyle ultimately ended up hampering
his battlefield prowess a bit which is
an unfortunate term for fans of Thor's
epic approach to combat from all of the
ups and downs that broth or character
goes through an ends game hands down one
of the best things about the entire film
is this final decision to join the
guardians of the galaxy while his
presence will be missed on the Avengers
the thoughts of an overweight
self-confident Thor unhampered by
responsibilities traipsing around the
cosmos with the guardians and search of
adventure is a definition of Awesome the
thought that the entire scenario will be
overseen in Guardians 3 by the offbeat
genius of director James Gunn makes it
that much more appealing from adding
some muscle to the already impressive
team to his ongoing bickering with
star-lord over who's really in charge
the possibilities are tantalizing we'll
have to wait and see if there's
guardians of the galaxy really will be a
full-length feature affair or if it will
just be a passing nod as Thor heads into
the unknown for a fourth solo film then
again maybe we'll get both here's hoping
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more loop of videos about
the MCU are coming soon subscribe to our
YouTube channel and hit the bell so you
don't miss a single one
you